-Vor der kaserne,
..vor dem grossen tor.
Stand eine laterne..
..und steht sie noch davor.
So wollen wir
uns da wiedersehen.
Bei der laterne..
..wollen wir stehen.
Wie einst Lili Marleen.
...
Et dans la nuit sombre,
..nos corps enlacés..
..ne faisaient qu'une ombre..
..lorsque je t'embrassais.
Nous échangions ingénument,
..joue contre joue..
..bien des serments.
Tous deux, Lili Marleen.
Le temps passe vite..
..lorsque l'on est deux.
Helas, on se quitte,
voici le couvre-feu.
Te souviens-tu de nos regrets..
..lorsqu'il fallait nous séparer ?
Dis-moi, Lili Marleen.
...
I knew you were waiting
in the street.
I heard your feet,
..but could not meet.
My own Lili Marleen.
Cette tendre histoire..
..de nos chers 20 ans..
..chante en ma mémoire..
..malgré les jours, les ans.
Il me semble entendre ton pas..
..et je te serre..
..entre mes bras.
Lili... Lili Marleen.
...